hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live drei Jahre ist es morgen schon her
dass die erste corona-infektion in
Deutschland bestätigt wurde unglaublich
oder manchmal kommt es mir so vor als
wenn das ganze wirklich schon richtig
lange her ich weiß nicht wie es euch
geht aber dann fühlt sich auch wieder
total nah an wenn jemand den man gut
kennt irgendwie erkrankt ist und während
die allermeisten nach einer Erkrankung
nach kurzer Zeit wieder fit sind gibt es
aber auch Menschen für die ist seit
Corona nie mehr Normalität
zurückgekommen seitdem ist nichts mehr
wie es war manche wurden eben nicht mehr
richtig gesund nachdem sie erkrankt sind
aber auch das es gibt Menschen wenn auch
weniger die offenbar obwohl sie sich mit
der Impfung schützen wollten mit der
corona-schutzimpfung danach krank
geworden sind besonders betroffen sollen
junge Frauen sein vorher sportlich und
gesund long kovet nach Impfung das ist
heute unser Thema und ihr könnt Fragen
dazu stellen im Stream oder per Mail mit
kommentieren und wir können nämlich in
dieser Sendung mit einer sprechen ihr
seht sie auch schon hier hinten auf dem
Monitorbild der genau das passiert ist
mit Schauspielerin fenic Felicia Binger
sie leidet an long kovid nach Impfung
und seitdem ist für Sie in Ihrem Leben
alles anders Keilriemen berichtet
erstmal kurz übersehen
Felicia Binger ist Schauspielerin 29
Jahre alt und seit ihrer corona-impfung
krank im Mai 2021 hat sich Felicia mit
dem Impfstoff von biontech gegen kobit
19 impfen lassen voller Überzeugung
postet sie das auf Instagram es war ihre
erste und bisher einzige Impfung gegen
das Virus vor der Impfung war Felicia
aktiv machte viel Sport und arbeitete
als Schauspielerin
mehr als anderthalb Jahre später geht es
ihr noch immer schlecht brennen am
ganzen Körper was von diesen
Gefäßentzündungen kommt nervenstechen
extreme Schmerzen am Körper
neurologische Schwierigkeiten heute muss
sie Medikamente nehmen und ist in
Behandlung raus geht sie kaum noch
Beitrag von kairem und Susanna Santina
und Finisher Binger ist jetzt bei uns
hallo
hallo für Lisa wie geht es Ihnen heute
also jetzt in diesem Moment wo wir
sprechen so lange Zeit es sind natürlich
jetzt auch vergangen seit dieser Impfung
ja also erstmal freut es mich natürlich
dass es mir überhaupt heute gut genug
geht um hier sitzen zu können weil das
für mich keine Selbstverständlichkeit
mehr ist leider darum schön dass ich
heute mit ihnen sprechen kann was ist
denn für sie die größte Herausforderung
seit dem in ihrem Leben also was hat
sich total verändert was können sie
nicht mehr machen
ja ich kann sehr vieles nicht mehr
machen also mein Leben beschränkt sich
auf Kleinigkeiten die ich noch kann auf
sehr viel pacing das heißt zwischendurch
immer wieder pauseneinhalten
gar nicht oder nur sehr wenig arbeiten
können weil es in meiner Branche eben
nicht möglich ist einfach nur mal zwei
oder drei Stunden zu arbeiten und vor
allem auch das Problem dass es leider
ein Thema ist was leider politisch ist
und die Betroffenen eigentlich einfach
nur unbedingt wieder gesund werden
wollen wenn sie sagen ein Thema das
politisch ist also inwiefern betrifft
sie das was sie meinen sie das genau
also zum einen dass ich sehr viel
Ablehnung erfahren habe von Ärzten die
mich nicht ernst genommen haben die mir
nicht geglaubt haben aber auch im Umfeld
hat man sehr gemerkt und tatsächlich
auch in meiner Branche also dass ja sich
Menschen nicht mehr bei mir gemeldet
haben sich weggeduckt haben und man so
ein bisschen das Gefühl hatte wie ja man
möchte mit diesem Schmuddelkindern
zu tun haben man möchte mit
impfgeschädigten nichts zu tun haben und
diese soziale Ächtung ist eigentlich mit
ein großes Problem und das erste Mal
wirklich ärztlich ernst genommen wurde
ich tatsächlich erst neun Monate nach
meiner Erkrankung nachdem ich schon
viele Fachärzte aufgesucht hatte dann in
der Ambulanz in Marburg mit Ihrem
behandelnden Arzt werden wir in dieser
Sendung auch noch sprechen können aber
verstehe ich das also richtig die
Menschen haben ihn nicht geglaubt dass
sie krank sind war das
richtig mir wurde es oftmals nicht
geglaubt es gibt dann ebenso die eine
Hälfte die sagt das kann überhaupt nicht
sein das gibt es nicht weil das eben von
der Politik oftmals zu vermittelt wurde
und dann leider auch eine andere Seite
die sagt na ja selbst schuld du hättest
dich besser darüber informieren müssen
und man er steht als erkrankte so ein
bisschen dazwischen und möchte
eigentlich einfach nur gesund werden man
möchte sein altes Leben wieder zurück
man möchte wieder arbeiten können man
möchte wieder das Unternehmen können wie
man es vorher gemacht hat und es ist nur
noch so wenig möglich und was hilft
ihnen überhaupt zur Zeit sie haben
gesagt das hat 9 Monate gedauert bis sie
sich ärztlich überhaupt wahrgenommen
gefühlt haben also respektiert gefühlt
haben aber was ist das was ihnen hilft
oder haben Sie noch gar keine Hilfe
Linderung wirklich gefunden
also zum einen nehme ich verschiedene
Medikamente unter anderem auch um zum
Beispiel die Nesselsucht zu unterdrücken
damit man mir das zumindest nicht
ansieht dann ist es auch eine ganz
bestimmte Art und Weise der Ernährung
also ich kann nur noch wenig
verschiedene Lebensmittel zu mir nehmen
und eben auch pacing das heißt wirklich
ganz aktiv ausruhen nicht über die
Grenzen gehen und ähm ja einfach sehr
viele Ruhepausen einplanen und sehr
viele Stunden am Tag liegen wir werden
auch später noch darüber sprechen wie
viele Menschen zumindest offiziell
anerkannt wurden die das betrifft aber
kennen Sie persönlich auch andere die
davon betroffen sind am Anfang schien
sehr sehr allein damit gewesen zu sein
er hat tatsächlich am Anfang habe ich
mich wahnsinnig damit allein gefühlt das
war auch der Grund warum ich dann
irgendwann aus lauter Verzweiflung dass
auf Instagram gepostet habe und was dann
kam an Nachrichten Fluten das kann man
sich gar nicht vorstellen so dass ich
eigentlich seit eineinhalb Jahren
seitdem ich krank bin permanent Versuche
anderen Betroffenen zu helfen weil es
eben einfach noch nicht die
Anlaufstellen gibt oder nicht genug
Anlaufstellen gibt und das war eben auch
etwas was mir wahnsinnig viel Kraft
gegeben hat also dieser Austausch mit
anderen Betroffenen den es eben oft auch
so geht die auch nicht ernst genommen
werden die auch dann eher eine
psychosomatische Diagnose bekommen als
eben wirklich ernst genommen zu werden
es gibt einige Kommentare auch schon bei
uns im Stream es gibt vor allem viele
Menschen die ihnen alles Gute wünschen
und eine schnelle Besserung das möchte
ich Ihnen auch mitgeben es gibt auch
noch einen User Micha Weißgerber der
schreibt bei Facebook ich habe nach der
dritten Impfung permanente
Muskelschmerzen aber einfach ruhig
bleiben um nicht als Querdenker
abgestempelt zu werden ist Ihnen das
auch passiert also dass Leute gesagt
haben sie sind sogenannter Querdenker
oder die gesagt haben sie haben
vielleicht einfach keine Lust mehr jetzt
auf weitere Impfungen sie glauben nicht
dass das Corona wirklich gibt wie ist es
ihnen da ergangen
ja das kann ich sehr gut nachvollziehen
also das ist auch ein Thema was gerade
mich weil ich damit an die
Öffentlichkeit gegangen bin massiv
betroffen hat wo ich wirklich ganz viele
schreckliche Anfeindungen bekommen habe
im realen Leben aber eben auch vermehrt
natürlich im Netz was mir auch
wahnsinnig schwer gefallen ist damit
umzugehen und ja ganz viele schweigen
darüber weil sie wahnsinnig wahnsinnig
Angst haben damit in der Ecke gedrängt
zu werden in der sie gar nicht sind weil
sie sind wir reden ja von geimpften
Menschen
paulier Petersen fragt sich was machen
sie jobmäßig denn heute haben sie sich
unorientiert wir haben ja gehört dass
sie in der Schauspielerei dann nicht
mehr wirklich Fuß fassen konnten
ja also ich hoffe da natürlich
einerseits dass sich die Gesellschaft
dann ein bisschen dreht was
impfgeschädigte angeht aber auch was
Menschen mit longkowith mit mecfs angeht
dass man da Lösungen finden kann und
hoffe dass ich in Zukunft wieder
arbeiten kann und dass keine politisches
Problem mehr ist wo man sich wegdrückt
und ich ja wieder arbeiten kann auch
wenn es dann kleinere Rollen sind z.B
das würde ich mir wünschen für die
Zukunft wer übernimmt dann die
Behandlungskosten wenn sie da jetzt in
ärztlicher Behandlung sind
ja das ist auch ein großes Problem denn
die Diagnostik die wichtig wäre wird
oftmals nicht bezahlt oder nicht oftmals
es sind eigentlich Blutwerte die man in
der Regel selbst bezahlt und auch
Behandlungsansätze die man in der Regel
selbst bezahlt weil wenn man in so einer
Situation ist und wirklich hat also man
hat wirklich Angst um sein Leben man hat
wahnsinnige Schmerzen man hat Lähmung
man kann nicht mehr gehen man ist zu
nichts mehr in der Lage und sucht dann
natürlich dringend Nachhilfe und nimmt
jeden Strohhalm der da kommt und
versucht alles und leider wird ja so gut
wie nichts davon bezahlt
zum Schluss noch die Frage die hier ein
User stellt eine Userin tryty works
fragt sich woher ist denn klar dass es
nicht einfach auch eine corona-infektion
gewesen ist ist bei ihnen das ganz
ausgeschlossen genau bei mir wurde das
ausgeschlossen es wurde da so nucleo
Capsid Test gemacht ich habe auch in der
Zeit davor tatsächlich sehr viel
gearbeitet wo ich also jeden Tag
getestet wurde hatte auch keine Symptome
darum ist es in meinem Fall
ausgeschlossen worden aber eine Sache
die interessiert mich doch noch dass wir
mir gerade noch ein was erhoffen Sie
sich denn jetzt das ist natürlich auch
ganz wichtig vielleicht auch gerade von
der Politik Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach der forderte ja schon auch
dass eben longkow wird nach Impfung das
wird von manchen auch postwachsen sind
rum genannt so wurde es auch von ihm
bezeichnet dass das besser untersucht
werden müsste also bessere Forschung Sie
ganz persönlich was erhoffen Sie sich
ja weniger Worte und mehr Taten ganz
massiv Studien natürlich dass die
Diagnostik gezahlt wird dass es
vereinfacht wird diesen Impfschaden
anerkennen zu lassen und schlussendlich
auch dass man genauer schaut also in der
Impfempfehlung wen trifft es und warum
und so weiter dass diese Fragen geklärt
werden und
es mehr Anlaufstellen gibt für
geschädigte
fordert Felicia Binger sie ist
Betroffene von longkow wird nach Impfung
vielen Dank dass Sie Ihre Geschichte
hier bei uns erzählt haben sich die Zeit
genommen haben danke schön danke schön
und behandelt wird Felicia Binger wir
haben das schon angesprochen von
Professor Bernhard Schiefer von der
postkowit-ambulanz an der Uniklinik
Marburg das ist eine Spezialambulanz für
Menschen die sich seit der kobit Impfung
krank fühlen und er ist jetzt auch bei
uns und wir können mit ihm noch mal ganz
tief in die Materie einsteigen schönen
guten Abend hallo guten Abend nochmals
natürlich die erste Frage die sich
aufdrängt die wir jetzt auch gerne mal
wissenschaftlich noch mal besprechen
wollen ist wie klar ist denn dieser
Zusammenhang von ihm longkowitz mit
Impfung oder nach Impfung
da streiten sich noch die Gelehrten das
ist nicht klar die Wissenschaft kann
nicht eindeutig nachweisen zu dem Punkt
kommt es zu bestimmten Veränderungen was
wir im Moment sehen was wir am
häufigsten sehen ist einfach Patienten
die jetzt 18 Monate oder so wie Frau
winger 9 Monaten nach einer Infektion
nach einer Impfung mit Corona
Impfstoffen dass die sich bei uns
vorstellen
sogenannte longkowitz Symptome
darstellen und wir müssen wirklich eine
mimikryarbeit das heißt wirklich
Detektive tätig sein um heraus zu
identifizieren wo das Problem eigentlich
ist
und hat das mit ihnen also hat das was
daran geändert dass sie jetzt auch haben
sie Zweifel an der corona-impfung
vielleicht tatsächlich das ist die
wichtigste Frage von Weg nein ich habe
keine Zweifel diese Impfung hat uns als
die Corona
Virusinfektion und drohten und wir die
Bilder von
hunderten von Toten in China und auch in
Norditalien vor uns hatten hat sie uns
schon vor allem in unseren kritisch
kranken Population geholfen die
Erkrankung zu bewältigen wir haben
gelernt wie wir Corona behandeln können
und jetzt geht es darum tatsächlich
diese longkurve der Erkrankung sie
wieder Bundesminister das auch schon
genannt hat von Grund auf zu erforschen
die molekularen Zusammenhänge zu
erklären um Therapie Ansätze zu finden
und das sehr sehr schnell sowas wie an
sich mit Frau mir das darf uns an sich
nicht passieren
jetzt gibt es natürlich auch Stimmen bei
uns in der Community aber eben auch in
der Gesellschaft wie jetzt hier
beispielsweise von Prince optional der
schreibt oder sie wie ich drangsaliert
terrorisiert und denunziert worden bin
in den letzten drei Jahren weil ich
nicht geimpft wurde und bin heute
kerngesund Halleluja und auch Niklas
schreibt also ich bin nicht geimpft und
mir geht's gut haben die dann Glück
gehabt oder freuen die sich zurecht wie
kann man das einordnen
das ist eine schwierige sehr emotional
geführte Diskussion
der ich am liebsten natürlich aus dem
Weg gehe ich weiß dass wir hoch Risiko
Patienten haben die wir geimpft haben
ich gehör unter anderem ja auch dazu im
im Krankenhaus wir arbeiten in der
Notaufnahme jeden Tag mit sich
corona-patienten
das ist eine eine Situation die ein
retrospektives denk an seiner
rückwärtsgewand des Denkens wir sind
jetzt drei Jahre in einer
corona-pandemie wir haben Menschen in
unserer Bevölkerung die sind nicht
geimpft wir haben Menschen die sind sehr
häufig geimpft aber wir haben auch
eine Menschen die haben
eine longkurved-erkrankung erlitten nach
Impfung und nach Infektion eine
longkowitz Symptomatik entwickelt und
wir müssen uns diesen diesen Patienten
die ja für uns eine neuartige Erkrankung
darstellen tatsächlich stellen und die
Erkrankung erforschen das ist das Credo
was die
die Wissenschaft hat und dafür braucht
es
Unterstützung für die
Grundlagenforschung es braucht
Studien die zeigen wie man die Therapie
adressieren könnte und letztlich
natürlich auch sowie Frau Binger das
auch gesagt hat eine gesellschaftliche
Akzeptanz das ist diese Menschen gibt
wir brauchen in unseren
Versorgungsstrukturen in unseren
Versorgungsämtern Menschen die sich
dieser Patienten annehmen
zwei Fragen weil wir haben ja jetzt also
genau die Geschichte von Frau Binger
also von einer betroffenen gehört aber
natürlich ist interessant zu wissen auch
was sind jetzt vielleicht die meisten
Symptome mit den Menschen bei ihnen
Vorsprechen also was haben die Menschen
was äußern die und dazu passt eben auch
noch anschließend von Marcel die Frage
bei Youtube was sind ihre
Behandlungsansätze dann dafür
dazu muss man muss man
das den Patienten sich individuell
anschauen bei uns in der Sprechstunde
braucht es ungefähr anderthalb Stunden
inklusive einer eine sehr breiten
Laboranalyse in Berlin an der Charité
ist es in ähnlicher Form werden die
Patienten in ähnlicher Form
aufgearbeitet
und nicht jeder Patient ist gleich
die Symptome mit denen die die Patienten
sich vorstellen sind
neurologischer
Art häufig Kopfschmerzen dieser berühmte
brainfox der auch vergesellschaftet ist
manchmal bei manchen Patienten mit einer
neuropsychiatrischen Veränderung eine
Auffälligkeit das gehört mit zu dem
Erkrankungsbild dazu das ist nichts
wodurch diese Patienten sich
diskriminiert fühlen müssen
es gibt die den großen Themenkomplex der
Herzprobleme
da wird im Moment sehr intensiv
diskutiert dass diese Herzprobleme
Rhythmusstörungen Herzschmerzen auch
herzmuskelentzündungen dass die
möglicherweise verantwortlich oder
beteiligt sein könnten an einer gewissen
Übersterblichkeit auch das muss dringend
untersucht werden und es gibt die große
Gruppe der Muskel und
Hautbeschwerden
Bewegungsstörungen manchmal
vergesellschaftet mit
Magen-Darm-Problemen also ein äußerst
buntes Bild und die Ursache dafür ist
mannigfaltig
und unser User dazu passt die Frage von
New Andy second fragt direkt an sie
hätte Frau Binger auch durch eine
corona-erkrankung solche Symptome
bekommen also gibt es einfach Menschen
die krank werden bei Kontakt mit dem
spike-protein
wissenschaftlich gesehen eine sehr sehr
spannende Frage der wir für uns
nachgehen wir sehen die Impfung als
Modell für eine corona-erkrankung ohne
die Auseinandersetzung mit einem Virus
ohne diese diese hyperinflammation die
in den ersten Tagen durch eine wäre
sogenannte verämie durch das überfluten
des Körpers mit mit einem Virus
stattfindet sondern wie uns interessiert
wie die Körper die hormonsysteme im
Körper auf dieses bikeprotein reagieren
und dieses bikeprotein hat etwas was für
Kardiologen sehr faszinierend ist es ist
nämlich so eine Art Schlüssel für
wichtige Blutdruck und Kreislauf
regulierende
hormonsysteme die die initial
Symptome von longkowitz sind
und jetzt die Frage ganz konkret hätte
Frau Binger das auch mit einer
corona-infektion erleiden können klar
es sind ja vor allem das haben wir in
der Recherche gelernt auch im Vorab das
hatten sie auch gesagt in Interviews
schon junge schlanke sportliche Frauen
betroffen da hat man dazu schon
Erkenntnisse warum das so ist auch
leading edge also wirklich
es gibt die Beobachtung auch wir haben
sie gemacht wir hatten im Anfang letzten
Jahres als wir angefangen haben
uns mit dem mit dem Thema intensiver zu
beschäftigen weil wir beobachtet haben
dass mehr und mehr dieser Patienten nach
einer corona-infektion nach einer
Impfung aufgetaucht sind in der Folge
auch der der Impfkampagne
beobachtet dass es vor allem junge
dynamische
mitten im Leben stehende Frauen sind
und haben das verifiziert mit einer
großen Umfrage bei der
75% aller unserer Patientinnen die an
sogenannten survey also ein
selbstreporting System
ausgefüllt haben europaweit im übrigen
über viereinhalb tausend junge Frauen
waren eben knapp 75% junge Frauen das
ist eine sehr dramatische Zahl jetzt
sagt das paul Ehrlich Institut das
Postfach so wie es ja auch genannt wird
also longo wird noch Impfung Postfach
stellt keine definierte Bezeichnung
einer Erkrankung da der Begriff meint
offenbar verschiedene Beschwerden wie
sie auch mit long koved in Verbindung
gebracht werden häufig fehlen allerdings
wichtige klinische Informationen so dass
die diagnostische Sicherheit oft nicht
beurteilt werden kann
diagnostische Sicherheit kann ich
beurteilt werden also heißt das es ist
unklar eben ob es das überhaupt gibt wie
ist das einzuordnen das ist ja
eigentlich nur andersrum adressiert dass
das was ich jetzt gerade gesagt habe sie
müssen sich die in einzelnen Patienten
anschauen sowie Frau Binger auch und
können nur nach Ausschluss von
beispielsweise einer stumm abgelaufenen
corona-infektion sagen dass es sich hier
um eine
longkowith oder postkowitz Symptomatik
wenn es schon länger dauert postkowitz
Symptomatik nach einer
Impfung handelt mehr mehr können sie
nicht sagen und wir haben in Deutschland
einen ein leider ein erhebliches Problem
was das Reporting betrifft da sind uns
die die Briten und auch die
skandinavischen Länder deutlich voraus
es wäre wünschenswert gewesen wenn wir
mit dem der der Impfkampagne eine
Registry gestartet hätten wo wir
tatsächlich solche Patienten
nachverfolgen können aber das ist jetzt
auch drei Jahre nach Beginn der
Impfkampagne ist das
wünschen kann man sich heute viel wir
müssen gucken dass wir die Patienten
behandeln weil jeder Tag den wir weiter
diskutieren und das hat Frau Binger ja
auch schon gesagt ist ein Tag wo
Menschen die vorher ganz regulär
gearbeitet haben aus dem Leben gerissen
sind sie sprechen dieses Sammeln der
Daten und Zahlen an dass paul Ehrlich
Institut das sammelt online die es nennt
sich ja offiziell Verdachtsfälle von
schwerwiegenden impfnebenden Wirkung
durch Kurve 19 im Stoffe so die sammeln
diese Zahlen und Daten und wie das genau
abläuft oder was da genau bekannt ist da
hat Josua schwarz nun einen Bericht
vorbereitet
bis zum 15 Januar wurden den paul
Ehrlich Institut
54.120 Verdachtsfälle von
schwerwiegenden impfnehmenwirkungen
durch kovid 19 Impfstoffe gemeldet bei
mehr als 190 Millionen Impfungen in
Deutschland entspricht das einer
Häufigkeit von rund
0,028%. schaut man sich die gemeldeten
Verdachtsfälle bei den verschiedenen
Impfstoffen an kommen bei den mRNA
Impfstoffen von moderner und biontech
Pfizer mit 0,02 bzw
0,025% am seltensten schwerwiegende
Nebenwirkungen vor höher liegt der
Anteil der Verdachtsfälle bei den Vektor
im Stoffen mit 0,045 % für Johnson
Johnson und 0,057 % für Astra scenica
beim proteinbasierten Impfstoff von
novawachs stehen
0,092% der Impfungen im Verdacht auf
schwerwiegende Nebenwirkungen
unter den gemeldeten schwerwiegenden
Verdachtsfällen waren Kurzatmigkeit
Herzrhythmusstörungen und
herzmuskelentzündungen am häufigsten
anders ist das bei den langandauernden
Nebenwirkungen nach corona-impfung die
Verdachtsmeldungen hierzu hat das
Paul-Ehrlich-Institut zuletzt Anfang
Juli ausgewertet und stieß auf 472 Fälle
in seiner Datenbank hier geht es um
lancouvert ähnliche Gesundheitsstörungen
am häufigsten das chronische
Erschöpfungssyndrom
472 Fälle im letzten Sommer sagt das
paul Ehrlich Institut wir haben es
gerade gehört deckt sich das mit ihren
Erkenntnissen so wie sie es eben
hochschätzen können
am liebsten würde ich mich an dieser
Diskussion nicht beteiligen aber wenn
sie mich so fragen ich glaube wir
sollten bei diesen 0,02 bleiben das ist
das was wir aus den Zulassungsstudien
wissen
das ist das was wir aus den
post-marketing Studien der
Impfstoffhersteller wissen und das deckt
sich auch ich sag mal ganz grob mit
unseren Erfahrungen und was für ein
registrierungsmeldesystem aber bräuchte
es ihrer Meinung nach in Deutschland wir
müsste das quasi aufgebaut sein das
melde-system wäre gut gewesen dass wir
wenn wir einfach jeden Patienten der
eine Dosis einer eines Impfstoffs
bekommt
in einem Register hätten mitlaufen
lassen so wie das in Großbritannien der
Fall ist beispielsweise im NS ist
funktioniert das ja
User Hubert Müller fragt sich wie hoch
ist die Dunkelziffer wenn sich viele
nicht trauen die Ursache in der Impfung
zu suchen kann man das abschätzen
nicht wirklich gut also man
ich weiß dass immer sehr viel über die
Zahlen diskutiert wird aber das hilft
denen die betroffen sind nicht wirklich
in der in der Umsetzung ihrer
Forderungen dass sie Behandlung brauchen
ich habe hier gerade noch viele
User-Kommentare gerade gesehen hier
Roman Flucht der fragt sich weil jetzt
haben wir ja auch schon gehört also von
Frau Binger es war für sie schwierig
eine Anlaufstelle zu finden wo man
flucht fragt sich warum gibt es keine
Anlaufstelle außer Marburg für im
Schäden
das ist die
möglicherweise ist der ist einer der
Gründe dass es ein Thema ist was nicht
so attraktiv ist das sehr viel
menschliche Einsatz braucht und auch
sehr viel
Verständnis und Sie können damit sich
keine Lorbeeren verdienen für uns ist es
ein wissenschaftlich
hochspannendes Thema und als Arzt
haben wir
und ich kann Ihnen da selber meine
Aha-Momente berichten ich habe vor
diesen Menschen gesessen und habe
nachdem ich jetzt 30 Jahre Medizin mache
gesagt
hier sind eine ganze Reihe Menschen
wirklich krank und ich habe keine Ahnung
was die haben keinen blassen Schimmer
und das ist mir noch nicht sehr häufig
passiert
und dann fangen Sie an zu lesen es gibt
Literatur weltweit sie unterhalten sich
mit Kollegen um den Globus herum
manches endet in einer Sackgasse manches
endet führt zu einer Idee mittlerweile
haben wir und die verschiedenen
Arbeitsgruppen in meiner Klinik und an
der philips-universität in Marburg eine
sehr klare Vorstellung davon was das
Problem sein könnte und ich hoffe dass
wir auch demnächst den den Schlüssel auf
den Tisch legen können wenn wir es dann
final bewiesen haben und es ist aber
mittlerweile an einem Punkt angekommen
wenn sie 4000 Patienten auf der
Warteliste stehen haben und im letzten
Jahr zweieinhalb tausend Patienten
zusätzlich zu denen die wir sonst auch
in unserer kardiologischen Klinik
behandeln noch zusätzlich behandeln und
Ihnen wird vor jeder Tür sozusagen an
diese klopfen und sagen wir brauchen
Hilfe bis auf ihre eigene ihr eigen Team
im eigenen Haus wird ihnen gesagt ja das
ist jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Thema was
für uns wichtig ist
da setzen wir auf unseren
Bundesgesundheitsminister der sagt wir
packen das Thema an weil wir brauchen
flächendeckend für unser Land eine
Versorgungsstruktur die sich dieser
Patienten annimmt
sie haben ihn angesprochen
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach den haben
wir auch heute Vormittag angesprochen
interviewt und er verspricht nun mehr
Geld für Forschung hören wir mal rein
ist eine sehr weit verbreitete
Erkrankung wenig erforscht und
insbesondere fehlt es an
Versorgungsforschung das heißt der
Erforschung wo wird das am besten
behandelt wie behandelt man sind zum
Beispiel
rehabilitationsaufenthalte notwendig
oder sind sie sinnvoll in die Art und
Weise in Deutschland behandelt wird ist
nicht gut strukturiert und auch nicht
gut untersucht von daher werde ich vom
Haushaltsausschuss hier 100 Millionen
Euro beantragen um ihr
Versorgungsforschung aufzubauen davon
werden auch diejenigen profitieren die
nach der Impfung sogenannte Post weg
also Symptome entwickelt haben das sind
viel weniger Menschen natürlich und das
in der Regel auch leichtere Symptome
aber trotzdem sondern auch nicht
zurückgelassen werden das wird hier mit
untersucht eine Größenordnung wie viele
Menschen an Post weg also leiden diese
Größenordnung können wir zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt nicht nennen weil dafür dass
Krankheitsbild durch die ausreichend gut
definiert ist
100 Millionen Euro das wurde
angesprochen Lauterbach hat aber auch
gesagt dass Krankheitsbild das sei noch
nicht genug definiert also was glauben
sie sind bei diesen 100 Millionen ist da
auch Geld für Marburg dann dabei wir
werden sehen
wir werden sehen was würden Sie sagen
also wie soll man muss man Betroffenen
besser gerecht werden wir haben unser
Konzept der
Sektor verzahnenden Versorgung auf den
Tisch gelegt zusammen mit der
Technischen Hochschule Mittelhessen das
Universitätsklinikum Gießen und Marburg
hat eine klare Vorstellung davon wie man
mit Unterstützung von verables und
künstliche Intelligenz zusammen mit
niedergelassenen Kollegen Facharztpraxen
barrierefrei diese Versorgung
stattfinden lassen kann wir haben
ambulante und auch stationäre
Versorgungsstrukturen auf die wir
zurückgreifen können wir haben Kollegen
die hoch engagiert sind wir können noch
mehr Kollegen gebrauchen die sich gerne
bei mir melden können wenn sie Lust
haben
sich diesem Thema zu widmen es ist
da ist Hessen in einer gewissen Weise
eine eine
Vorreiterfunktion zugeschrieben weil wir
diese
corona-versorgungsstrukturen etabliert
haben die wir jetzt in die Post
corona-phase übertragen und sind
wirklich in einer glücklichen Position
wo wir barrierefreie Versorgung
gewährleisten können
zum Schluss noch die Frage hier aus dem
Stream von Vera sie fragt wann kommt ein
icd-code für Post weg und eine Leitlinie
für Diagnostik und Therapie sie schreibt
außerdem danke für dieses Jahr für den
Mut und war Mut weiter für uns
Betroffenen zu sprechen
also im icd-code den gibt es schon es
gibt die Nebenwirkungen nach einer
corona-infektion das hat die WHO
etabliert das ist auch der ist auch in
Deutschland eingeführt worden wenn ich
mich richtig entsende war es Oktober
letzten Jahres
genauso wie es long kovid nach
Infektion ebenfalls als anerkannte
Erkrankung gibt und
wir brauchen die so sehr feste
therapiealgorithmen sind im Moment
schwierig zu etablieren weil wenn sie
sich runtergeschrieben haben und
konsentiert haben mit allen
Berufsgruppen und allen
Interessensgemeinschaften haben sie im
Prinzip können Sie sich schon an die
nächsten an den nächsten Algorithmus
setzen weil die Wissenschaft schreitet
hier wirklich sehr sehr schnell voran
das sagt Professor Bernhard Schiefer von
der postkowitambulanz an der Uniklinik
Marburg vielen Dank Herr Schiefer dass
sie sich so lang Zeit für unsere Fragen
genommen haben
danke schön
und Felicia Binger wollen wir natürlich
zum Schluss auch noch mal dazu holen wir
haben die ganze Zeit jetzt auch
teilweise natürlich über sie gesprochen
sie sollen natürlich das letzte Wort
auch zum Ende der Sendung haben ich habe
auch in den Kommentaren eben von vielen
gelesen hoffentlich haben sie es gerade
gehört ich habe es auch gerade eben noch
mal vorgelesen also sie sind nicht
alleine das haben sehr Gott sei Dank
auch schon gemerkt sondern es gibt auch
eben einige in den Kommentaren die an
ihrer Seite stehen die also den ist auch
so geht Frau Binger wir haben jetzt noch
mal viel gesprochen und dem Thema
gewidmet und sie haben eben gerade so
auch noch mal den ozonen und das
Gesundheitsminister gehört ist das etwas
was ihnen Hoffnung gibt zum Schluss die
Frage also wie schauen Sie in die
Zukunft natürlich auch wie könnte es
weitergehen sie sind natürlich Expertin
in dem Thema inzwischen
ja ehrlich gesagt hat es mich gerade
erst mal komplett fassungslos gemacht
wie er das Problem wieder runtergespielt
hat das deckt sich einfach nicht mit dem
was ich sehe mit den Müttern die mich
ansprechen mit ihren Kindern die im
Rollstuhl sitzen nach der Impfung also
wir reden davon so schweren Schäden und
das schockiert mich das Lauterbach immer
noch behauptet das sei nicht so schlimm
ich denke das könnte auch Professor
Schiefer bestätigen dass das einfach
leider so nicht stimmt und daher bin ich
da jetzt noch vorsichtig mit meinen
Hoffnungen denn er hat das Thema schon
mal angesprochen das war im Juni letzten
Jahres und seitdem ist überhaupt nichts
für uns passiert und darum hoffe ich
dass jetzt wirklich Taten folgen weil es
ist nicht 5 vor 12 Uhr es ist viertel
nach und die Organschäden und andere
Schäden dieser Menschen streiten in
dieser Zeit weiter voran und ich hoffe
er hält Wort und tut jetzt wirklich was
für Betroffene
sagt Felicia Binger vielen Dank dass Sie
so lange in der Sendung bei uns waren
eine Betroffene von longkowitz nach
Impfung vielen Dank Frau Binger vielen
Dank Frau jung
und wir haben gelernt also jetzt
wirklich drei Jahre nach Corona 3 Jahre
wo uns das schon beschäftigt ist das
Thema immer noch nicht zu Ende und wir
werden also auch noch weiter darauf
schauen und für euch natürlich immer
dran bleiben deswegen danke schaut immer
wieder vorbei für die Aufmerksamkeit
heute und bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss